une épouse et une mère dévouée une
grand-mère attentionnée Joyce était une
femme formidable
je vous présente claire c'est l'une de
ces plus anciennes amis elle s'était
connu à l'université
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
maintenant qu'elle est morte je vais
faire ça ce weekend
[Musique]
il faut que je te parle me parle de quoi
je lui ai dit que j'allais le tuer
on peut en causer
45 ans aujourd'hui
pour moi c'était hier tu délirais elle
m'a dit que tu étais un homme cruel et
pour un garçon bon alors c'est quoi ton
plan je vais m'acheter une arme
ravissante et je la prendrai à la
veiller funèbres comment elle recule le
recul je vais pas vous mentir il y a une
secousse
j'ai une capsule de cyanure au cas où je
serai capturé par l'ennemi je peux te la
donner aux
Oscars malcolm McDowell et Richard
des femmes qui se plaignent et qui ne
sont pas faites pour le bonheur je crois
hélas que tu n'es pas fait pour le
bonheur je suis partante pourquoi
semaine qui s'est annulé alors je suis
libre tu m'as manqué tu avais mon numéro
toi aussi tu avais mon numéro alors on
est aussi nul l'une que l'autre une
Fonda et une alchimie géniale non c'est
pas ça
[Musique]
mais qu'est-ce que tu fais avec ce
couteau oh j'avais l'intention de
poignarder quelqu'un
c'est qui
c'est Ralph on a fait l'amour la nuit
dernière tu as un préservatif manquerait
plus que je commence